Look at them Ramadan Muslims there, man
Ramadan comes
They go to the Masjid, they do Taraweeh and stuff (murmures)
Really and truly... I mean.. Outside of Ramadan... what? You know ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Ali: We shouldn't judge them, akhi, because this might be a turning point for them. I know a lot of brothers and sisters--
Yes in Ramadan, they're practicing and doing this
and sometimes, they (were)... kinda doing bad habits before.
But there's a lot that actually change during Ramadan, Inshallah, so let's give them that chance, Inshallah
May Allah bless them
Hope you guys enjoyed that video! Don't forget to share, subscribe and like
And join the Dawah movement
By becoming a Dawah movement member today by clicking the link below